2020 was a year of changes and
challenges to our daily lives brought on
by the pandemic of course a recent
american psychological association study
found 65 percent of adults say the
amount of uncertainty in the nation
causes them stress well no one can
forecast exactly how 2021 will unfold
there are actually experts who not only
predict what's possible
but are optimistic about it erica orange
is a futurist and partner
with the future hunters the consulting
firm helps clients in tech
pharmaceuticals and government identify
trends that
could affect businesses erica welcome
happy new year thanks so much for being
with us this morning
happy new year thank you so much for
having me so after we
the covet restrictions finally lift what
areas so many
so many areas of business and the world
have been affected have been changed at
least in the short term
what do you expect will be permanently
changed by this
yes so there's one very important thing
to note and that is the fact that we are
being shot through what we call the
covid accelerator
it's like we're being shot through a
cannon and almost overnight
global circumstances have changed
dramatically
and this is really setting the stage for
everything that we see happening when it
comes to the future of work
there are two critical points within
this covet accelerator
the first is that whole industries
whether it's in health and medicine
retail hospitality they are being forced
to pivot
in real time and permanently in response
to these unprecedented
conditions and businesses are also being
forced
to completely re-engineer everything
from their supply chains
to their operations to even their entire
workforces
to prevent future disruptions like covet
from putting them out of existence
now the second trend oh yes go ahead
well i was just going to
pick up what you were saying about work
you know because i feel i was shot out
of a cannon right into my tv room
and i don't like working from home i
know a lot of people do
and it certainly has been a game changer
what do you think is going to happen
i'm glad we're back in the studio but
what do you think is going to happen
when it comes to working
remotely in 2021 is this going to
continue
i think it absolutely is going to
continue but i think we're going to see
the hybridization of work so we're going
to continue to see a distributed
workforce
even when we go back to normal erica
even you've got the vaccine and
everybody's healthy
and everybody's fine you think we will
still be working from home is what i
mean
yes even after we get the vaccine uh
people are still going to be nervous
about going into a physical office
although at the same time those that do
have to report to a physical office
they're going to need that space to be
redesigned and reinvented
so whatever what i mean by that is the
fact that we need to rethink what that
physical workplace even looks like
people are going to want to be spaced
out they might want sophisticated
technologies like hvac systems
or even self-cleaning elevator buttons
so that they're more comfortable going
into these spaces
and this is going to be even more
pronounced in the major cities
where people are much more crammed
together we're also going to be seeing
many more people relying on automation
they're going to want less kind of human
to human touch points
and want robots or sophisticated ai to
come in
and fill that void so that they are more
comfortable going about their day-to-day
lives well erica
i i want to talk about the future of
cities for a second because if
people are going to be working from home
or there's going to be a distributed
workforce as you say
what does that mean for the many
thousands of restaurants and shops
selling
coffee and a quick snack on the way to
work or a salad at lunch
i mean there's an entire business
infrastructure set up around
people going to the office for at least
eight hours a day
just like how work is going to be
completely reinvented
and reimagined we too have to reinvent
and reimagine
our physical cities transportation and
infrastructure are going to go through
tremendous changes
and you mentioned restaurants and even
just going to a coffee shop
being based in new york city i see a lot
of these proprietors having to reinvent
how it is that they reach out to
uh workers when they aren't coming into
a physical office it's why the entire
supply chain
is being disrupted that's what i mean
when i say entire operations need to be
rethought because we're not going to
be commuting in the same way going in
and returning home at five
we're going to be seeing this
non-linearity of work when essentially
time and space are becoming
uh kind of more muffled and we're not
going to be experiencing life and work
in the same manner
erica what about travel it's for many of
us it's still hard to imagine getting on
a plane again when that finally happens
is it going to be different do you think
it's going to be different and i see it
playing out on both ends of the spectrum
and what i mean by that is we're going
to see the growth of
high-tech travel and on the other end
we're going to see the growth of
low-tech travel so on the high tech end
we see many more people being
comfortable
using these blended reality platforms
whether it's augmented reality or
virtual reality to immerse themselves in
these far-fund places
that they can't go to now whether it's
nature halfway across the world
so that they can immerse themselves in
something that
is sensory and kind of delights all of
our senses
but you can do it from the comfort of
your own home on the low-tech side
we're seeing many more people engage in
kind of nostalgic acts of travel
they are packing up the family into an
rv they are taking cross-country trips
they are visiting the national parks
they are kind of going back to basics
and just engaging in much more
simplistic acts of travel
so we're seeing both of these happen at
the same time all right very interesting
like the headlamps on that rv you've
let us see a little bit into the future
just enough to keep going forward anyway
eric orange thank you very much